[Music]  foreign  okay you got seven minutes stay focused  the art in here is worth millions  proceed to step two  what's happening  it won't open sorry man you're on your  own  foreign  number three  number three come in  help me get me out of here  got a Tonkin Square Park  do that for me  [Music]  I'll tell him I'm stuck here  [Applause]  nobody here but us pigeons  [Music]  I feel you brother I gotta set you free  when I was a kid My teacher asked me  what I would say from my house if it  were on fire  I answered a Sketchbook my AC DC albums  and my cat Grouch up I didn't mention my  parents or my sister  does that make me a bad person  cats die  music face  but art  for Keeps  [Music]  [Music]